how are you doing today sir
i'm good have you ever seen the movie
office space steve i have seen the movie
office space many times
that space behind you looks like when he
gets
gets told he has to go downstairs and
like the little tiny cubicles
no space i don't i don't have a red
stapler but if i did it would be perfect
there you go you know just you know but
but anyway
so not the way i expected this to start
i'm gonna let me
first say that i loved this movie and
your performance in it
um it's it was so great and uh that's
really all i have so i'm gonna leave now
and uh no but but being
being serious um this a script like this
and a role like this only comes along
once in a while
um so what actually did you pay to be in
the movie
um well i told them that uh they would
never have to pay me for any future
roles that i played
and that i would just do uh no i don't
know man i i was just
so blessed and and it was a it was a
the dream role you know it's like what
do you what do you say you know you get
to play
cassius play regina king's directing
leslie odom jr is playing sam cook
i mean it's just like you know what can
you say
completely um do you what's what's crazy
about this movie is even though it's
taking place in 1964
it's as relevant today and what's going
on today as it was
in that hotel room back in 64. um
do you think and it's kind of like a
serious question but do you think
that the past year with what's been
going on in society
with black lives matter and with with
everything that feels like it's going on
do you feel like we're at a transition
period
do you feel like something's actually
happening or do you think it's going to
be
still decades to come
i mean for me as a black man i feel like
it's always
at the highest stakes you know in terms
of my
interactions with police my interactions
with society
what i am able to say and not say
authentically
um in in terms of in my career you know
so
um do i think we're at a watershed
moment i think a lot has
been brought to the to the forbearance
but i mean they thought that back in the
60s
you know and i remember when obama got
elected people thought that was the end
of racism you know so
um i just think that this is a something
that's going to be
continually something that we have to
stay on top of and continue to work
uh work for and work toward i understand
um
i jumping in to talk to to filming the
stuff in the hotel room
i'm curious how do you as an actor get
ready
when everyone you can feel like
everyone's bringing their a
game and i'm curious like what was it
like for you getting ready to film these
scenes
and working out the staging and
everything that went into it
it was uh it was it was a little bit of
um
i don't want to say overwhelming but i
was definitely the least
uh experienced in that aspect you know
you're talking about leslie who had
already done
hamilton um aldis who had already been
in you know um
straight out of compton so these guys
have been a part of big ensembles in the
past
and uh i was i was a hair behind in
terms of the blocking
and and in terms of like those types of
aspects and sometimes i would have ideas
and we'd already have locking locked in
and they'd be like you gotta you gotta
have it already so it's like
high-speed chess almost you know where
you're strategizing and you're paying
attention and you have to be ready for
whatever
you're getting to respond instantly um
and so
the great the benefit that i have was i
was so prepared in my character
that i never had to wonder how caches
would respond
or how would caches move i already knew
because i was just
it was already instinctual for me to
respond with his responses
um and that was that was essential when
you're when you're you know the one kind
of
feeling when you're the youngest of the
group a lot of actors i've spoken to
will try and stay in character in
between takes and while they're on set
to keep that mindset going
for you were you always staying in his
always the whole time from the time i
landed in new orleans until
till we got back um and then i you know
once covet hit and all that stuff then i
kind of dropped it and picked it back up
in
in the last scene that we shot um that
we picked up in la but
you know the entire time in new orleans
i was in caches um
you know and it was funny because the
way people would react to you when
you're
when you're portraying casual clay it
shows you how much they love him because
they'll treat you like him
they'll say oh champ you don't got to
pay for that champ don't worry about it
i said all right man thank you
thank you you know and uh you know
people would give me gifts on set you
know workout equipment
gloves they want me to sign things not
as eli as
cassian you know like it was just
amazing the the amount of love
and um connection that he still
has you know it just shows how amazing
he was do you feel like your cast
has really only met you recently because
you stayed in character for so long
i mean i don't know we we met you know
before we started shooting for a brief
period in la and then
in this whole promotional process since
the film has like
really caught uh a lot of attention at
film festivals and
and then the press uh we spent a lot of
time with each other on zooms and stuff
like that so
i feel like they know me but um it
definitely you know during that period
of time i think we all were
locked in and it was it was a very
focused period of time when we were
shooting
it really shows in the movie again i
loved it and i loved your performance um
thank you so much for your time
i wish you nothing but the best i
appreciate it god bless and thanks thank
you